I feel like I should do this too like
well doing this video do you have one
no I don't have any toys
so hey guys listen i'm ryan the right
Danny T baby girl sing silent night on a
sybian simple pickup here we go baby do
it you might want to watch this because
this is gonna be a good test for you
Danielle's already done crazy Sydney and
stuff I've already done she's into the
freaky [ __ ] she's into like all of the
freaky [ __ ] what is that I'm we're
talking poodle dogging [ __ ] in her mouth
free dogging oh yeah no [ __ ] on
people's faces
no crab dogging talking all kinds of
dogging just dog in dog out that's weird
hey you don't have any ol sex though
anyway guys poop stories that is not an
attractive image you don't like the
paint's off
the pink stalk the vagina ah it's so
crazy to perform in here no we're not
allowed to put porn I hear this is
YouTube but wait till we get up
partnership with for now babe you can
watch reactions girls sing silent night
on a sybian don't know if this is real
or a sketch let's find out
[Music]
they're pretty that's good yeah that's a
great start a not-so-silent night
[Music]
this porn stars what's a Symbian I
totally forgot
[Music]
she's so it did it
[Music]
just committed to that
[Music]
I think I'm going to hell it's your
dress
[Music]
Wow
like she's not even distracted hey guys
if you thought that was cool
wait until you see what we have coming
up the only way to know is to press
taxes right there I'll see you soon he's
calling for a simple pickup that's the
channel guys if you guys want to
subscribe to them they have an uncut
sibian ride of Jenna I don't want to see
her she like freaks me out the most
that's weird when she just got like it's
like whoa you just went for it
would you guys simian would I get one
like on our own on a regular basis or
what yeah something funny like that
something you consider it funny funny it
was funny but I'm thinking I'm like off
I'm into like you know baby this is what
simians look no no it's not I don't like
it's in her I don't think it's in ur I
think it just vibrates doesn't go in you
and then you let it vibrate no way that
was in then yeah I changed your mind
around here are we Danielle is getting
you know more on one even a known one
oh we're gonna keep it it doesn't matter
you live alone with your voice doesn't
matter ice like clean I don't know any
storage room these are the reasons why
I'm like I barely want to keep like it
looks like it was incredibly pleasurable
for him then is him I mean like yeah but
feel like I don't need to do that on a
regular basis
is your boyfriend satisfactory enough
for this situation hey hey buddy
how's my representation coming along do
you want to buy one for your girlfriend
I would love to buy one for Veronica
because I can't vibrate unless if there
is a way where I could just like shake a
lot you can create some sort of
vibrating simulation what about a um
Cochran Cochran would I get a Cochran
are those my pretty thing
what are those I don't know I don't know
anything about toys you don't know mmm
was a Cochran it's like you put on your
peanuts and I vibrates I was even sound
comfortable oh it's not for you but it's
fun I mean I've always thought
flashlights might be cool why would you
need that when you already have one I
know that's the reason I don't have one
my friend was dating this guy and she
like went to his bathroom and like
opened it up and there was all these
like flashlights and doors like it's
just a masturbation toy it's like even
if like if a girl has a dildo it's not
like you already have a penis is the
dildo you have significantly bigger than
your boyfriend's penis no but it
vibrates that's a good part that's a
good part
it's big but it vibrates that's not
bigger than cuts no um I mean it's like
no but like it vibrates that's the good
part that's the part people care about I
just know if I got one for Veronica
she's gonna want a bigger one than mine
like I have let her down in so many ways
and this is one of them well that's why
you get her the big yeah no I'm gonna
get her the sibian cuz I know that it's
so big I mean I've been pretty tired
lately you know and I like to actually
perform it's like but I want her to be
satisfied so if I get her the sibian
okay thought about that what if he's
like so good that she doesn't you know
want to have sex with me again ever
is a real-life problem yeah that's why
you don't let your girlfriend sleep with
male hookers kids don't and if you do
you wear a condom you are a condom
please refer back to video 807 you need
to learn how to use one properly what do
you think of the girls I mean like some
of them are hot and some of them were
not Yeah right
some of them actually were we're a
good-looking that's cool that made it
more entertaining yeah we're just doing
judgment cute that girl was the
prettiest which one no that girl is
pretty no no you hated her hate that
girl was cute which one's cute hideous
like them cute that girl's cute horrible
horrible
now one called the dark hair with the
big boobs that were coming out um oh I
think I know you're talking about we'll
find her I think yeah that one now yeah
okay yeah she's pretty yeah she's pretty
she's cute too
I'm glad we were able to decide pretty
or not they should doing one of the guys
that'd be so funny over the sibian yeah
I would try that I would so try that
depends how big it is about how thick it
is how big it is for four laughs sure
you would put a giant dildo that
vibrates in your ass in front of camera
[Music]
viral video people isn't that the point
to become successful on YouTube I'm
trying to picture it how's it looking
good just like go man probably take a
huge [ __ ] afterwards right over it no I
bet no don't include my cats they would
are they wouldn't this is happening at
YouTube studios not here Thank You
YouTube for letting me borrow the
backlog listen guys if you're new to the
channel subscribe today become a reject
it's the coolest thing you [ __ ]
gonna do danielle has an Instagram
nothing but butthole pictures just up in
person blows up on my my friends my
family yeah not just me yeah and it's
not set to private her account is just
public for everyone to view it click
quick some videos some slo-moes some
fast ones
well hon Tyagi
shoutout hey Ryan just want to tell you
that you are so original haha quotation
marks then others parentheses Tyrone ah
he's being an [ __ ]
what does I mean and that's one of the
million reasons that we love you your
reactions are cap legit and those
million subscribers are not far love
from India oh he's from India oh my god
let's see what you look like buddy
you're one of the few subscribers who
looks trustworthy Wow Wow dude okay dude
you look so nice I wasn't you got a
wonderful coat you look like you'd be a
wonderful lover in bed and I want you to
represent all the people from India to
for us yeah let them know Danielle and
Ryan say hi to India let them know let
them know you're in charge of all the
Indian folks are the bows and arrows and
stuff right know that we're not part of
what he just said that's Yeah right the
bows and arrows and arrows yeah I said
this on a video for an Indian trailer
and it fits a lot of Indian people off
so I'm I'm just trying to oh I know what
you're about do you guys again India